I have thyroid antibodies. I have a thyroid antibodies for 30 years. Chronic line had
mold colonization. I have an acropath, so done a stack of cleansing. I don't appear to react to
immune stimulants such as cat's clock, a straggolus, andrographis and acnesia, although I take
the latter to less frequently. I'm not sure what this person means by that they don't react to it,
whether they don't react negatively or doesn't help them with a positive standpoint. I use AO
bio-residents and have come up with high ocarotoxin and some citrinated at MPA. Those are all
microtoxins. The microtoxin test I did six months ago. I'm impressed by your cute
product and AI products. Those are products that I formulated for auto-reviewed issues and
live conditions. Question which of these would you believe would be beneficial? My scanner on the
bio-residents is consistently telling me that I need anti-microbials and Artemisidia
cannula as well as mushrooms. Okay, so it's a long question. First of all, if a person has thyroid
antibodies and you're still showing up showing TPO or thyroid globular antibodies, that means that you
either have Hashimoto disease or Graves disease if it's a hyperthyroid state. I assume
that it's a hypothyroid, Hashimoto's. If that is still true, you still show positive antibodies
to thyroid. This is 30 years old and you're still having issues. That's why you're asking the question.
I would suggest that you consider at least doing some other antibody testing. So when a person has
antibodies to self-tissue, that means every time you stimulate an immune response, either artificially
stimulated immune response from exogenous source of sources, and by this I mean that you're
purposely trying to stimulate the immune system to kill some pathogen or something like
you're taking vitamin C or you're taking some of these products that this person mentioned,
cats claw, straggalists, endograbists, echinacea. These are all immune-stimulated herbs. So if you're
taking immune-stimulated herbs, so again, you're trying to stimulate your immune system for whatever
reason from an outside-in source where you're taking supplements to do that, and you have self antibodies,
you will, the danger of doing that is you will destroy self-tissue. So remember, when you stimulate
your immune system, either from an exogenous source, you're taking supplements to try to kill something,
or from an endogenous source meeting that your immune system is up-regulated because you are exposed
to a virus, or you get a cold, or you get a, you know, a sore throat or something, and your immune system
increases production of killer cells. You're going to kill that once you have antibodies against,
first, that's a whole idea of having antibodies. So if you have self antibodies,
we need antibodies to self-tissue, meaning you have an autoimmune disease, and you have an uptick
of your immune system, you will cause more destruction of that tissue. So that's what you have to be
careful about if you have an autoimmune disease. So this is a major, major mistake that people make,
if they don't know that they have an autoimmune disease, but it's never been discovered
why because it's never been tested for. The only way you're going to know if you have an autoimmune
disease is if you tested for self antibodies. Now, it's fairly common that a person would test
for thyroid antibodies because if you're really going to do a proper thyroid workout, you're going
to test for TPO and thyroid globular antibodies, which that doesn't really account for anything because
even you're going to an endocratologist for hypothyroidism, they never even test for antibodies,
believe it or not, which is absolutely bound to practice. But many times people don't test for other
antibodies. I mean, it's not, they might test for ANA antibodies, which is a systemic autoimmune
disorder. They might test for lupus. In other ways, they might test for antibodies to different
viruses, like it's not uncommon to get an MC-MAR virus antibody test. But it is relatively
less common that a person goes to a doctor, even a functional medicine doctor, and they do appropriate
antibody testing. I think that can be an error. I think it's always wise to rule out other autoimmune
disorders, meaning that do you have antibodies to neural tissue? Do you have antibodies to other
tissues so that you know if you have an autoimmune disease, then you know you have to be careful
in using different nutrition the wrong way. So I'm all for using herbals to stimulate an immune
response to kill cancer, or to kill a bacterial infection, or a chronic bacterial infection.
But if you have, if you're doing that with a person, and you have auto antibodies,
when you have antibodies to self-tissue, or you would never test it for these, then you could actually
do more harm than good, because forever, every time you increase the immune response,
either artificially through using herbals, like I said, you will kill that with your antibodies
again, so I think you should test for that. So what should you use? I mean, the reason why I created
that acute LX, chronic LX, and the AI products is that I really created them with, in the mind,
if a person has acute Lyme disease, or acute viral infection, or acute bacterial infection,
a chronic Lyme disease, chronic viral infection, chronic bacterial infection, that would be the
acute LX and a chronic LX, and then the AI is, if you're in the autoimmune phase, there's no
immune stimulants in there. So if you're going to try to support your body, when you have an autoimmune
disease, you can't be using TH1 stimulants, you can't be using immune stimulants. So if you want my
advice on what you should take, you should only take the AI product, or something similar to that,
if you look at the ingredients on our store site, you'll want to purchase something similar,
that if you have something similar in your cabinet, the idea is that you're not taking things that
are going to be immune stimulants. My scanner tests that I need for antimicrobials,
well, again, your scanner might test for the need for antimicrobials, which your scanner cannot
test for auto antibiotic. So you have to be, I guess, a more broad spectrum practitioner in the
fact that you're going to look at auto antibiotics. So if a person comes up that they have a viral
infection, or a product bacterial infection, you still don't just jump on that way, you're going to
try to kill that virus, or kill that bacteria without looking at the bigger picture. You've got to
test for auto antibodies, and you already know, you have thyroid auto antibodies, you just have to know
that if you're going to take a via stimulants, you're going to kill more of your thyroid, and you could,
even if it's been fairly balanced, and you've been able to keep it in balance with what other things
you're doing, then you could throw it away out of balance. Artemisidid, Artemisidid, Artemisia
adiwa, which is Artemisidid, is an immune stimulant. So Artemisidid is a great antiviral. It's a
great product for product line, but what's product line goes into that phase three, and that's
an auto immune phase that you have to be careful with, Artemisidid. Mushrooms are your safe or
bad, because mushrooms are not direct immune stimulants. Mushrooms are more immune regulators,
meaning if you need an uptick and an immune response for a period of time, it will help uptick that
if your immune system is already in a hyper-functioning state. In many cases with auto immune disease,
it will call that down. So mushrooms tend to act more as an immune regulator. That is dose dependent,
more and more studies are coming out that different nutrients work in your body differently,
dose dependently. So I would say if you're going to take high dose of Rishi or my attack eat,
it's going to be more of an immune stimulant. If you're going to take a lower dose of those
things, it could act as a more immune regulator. Cortiseps and terti-tail are going to be more
immune regulators. You're going to have to go pretty high dose for it to be more of an immune
stimulator. Okay, so I hope that helps. I didn't tell you exactly what to take, but really to do
more testoretically what we want.